welcome back to age 20 special
relativity so we're going to continue
the discussion and make the case against
ether for discussing stellar operation
so the problem we have in mind here is
the ones where we use a telescope to
look at a distant star
when we do this
the effect of ether might change the way
we have to orient our telescope let's
have a look at this
so we are in a situation that our
hypothesis is that the ether exists this
carries is the medium in which light
travels
but it's dragged with earth
in that situation that is our case
number one
in that situation
uh the telescope looks at the star with
the the light of the of the star enters
our telescope at the top
and then tries to go to the bottom
because the medium in which the light
travels and the telescope moves with the
same velocity remember the ether is
dragged with zeros
the
light appears to go straight down in the
telescope
without that lowercase 2 without the
either being tracked or even exist
we actually do have to
um slightly tilt our telescope
why because when the
after the light hits the top
of our telescope the telescope keeps
moving because it's in a different
reference frame and therefore we have to
have this slight tilting and
the value of the tilt is equal to
velocity of the earth
this is a very known effect in
astrophysics um and by the way
was already studied
way earlier by james bradley in the
1720s
um
he actually developed
not really supported theory of light
they was talking about particle nature
of light
and so his idea was it you know very
similar to case two that you know
reverse is moving in a different
reference frame with respect to the star
and the sun is moving around the sun
and therefore the tilting angle needs to
be
tangent of the tilting angle needs to be
equal to the distance of the rest of the
sun in the distance
this angle is very very small because
the nearest star you are able to observe
is about four light years away
so with this now we can again
do our
ether where this particle nature
model comparison
so in our first discussion we concluded
clearly
clearly
that the weighted ether
[Music]
hypothesis dominates or wins but now we
have studied at least two
uh further experiments so again i invite
you to stop here and think about how
stellar operation and michael simoli
could be answers with the particle model
or wave model kind of explanation
there's a third experiment that's
resolved every experiment that we
haven't did not discuss this year
all right so
for stellar aberration the particle
model actually seems to work as it was
proposed separately uh to solve this
very problem
uh and the michael
moly experiment also is consistent with
the particle model so now we are in this
dilemma that there are some experiments
or experimental evidence for particle in
either nature and some for a particle
nature of light
so the question now is how do we get out
of this dilemma and we'll
of the next lectures